We're going to hit record on this and we're going to get started.
I trust you can all see my screen and we're ready to go.
So you can see my screen there.
And it is the sixth of the sixth month in 2018.
And we're ready for today's Zoom call.
Today, we're going to get right in it because we've had a couple requests of people
that have said, if it's possible to try to keep these at our promised half hour,
actually, when we originally started doing these, we said we were going to be 15 minutes
so they keep getting longer and longer and I do apologize for that.
They're getting to be over and over and longer.
So let me just jump right into this.
Thanks to watch for coming up.
We're going to have what's called a seven day soulclubs.
Quite honestly, after I started writing this and put it together, it's not longer.
It's have a day, so I'm going to change title and that, but that remains to be seen.
That will be coming up.
The other thing we have a whole bunch of new data on anemia and cancer that I've been studying
about.
That's very interesting information since it's very difficult to deal with anemia of chronic
disease.
I'm actually going to put a video together that I'll post up on Facebook prior to next week's
Zoom call that maybe answer some questions that anybody might have after they watch that
video, because what has been called anemia of chronic disease, that's a type of anemia in
the medical textbooks, is very common with cancer patients and other people that are very
ill.
With cancer patients, the reason is another reason.
With other people that are very ill, they can have internal bleeding causing anemia of
chronic disease, like an internal hemorrhage or a chronic gastritis where they have a bleeding
ulcer.
That would be an anemia of a chronic disease.
That's a slow bleeder that you can't really find out where it is.
But with cancer, it's usually not a bleed, it's usually because the cancer is gobbling
up, iron, causing anemia.
Well, there's some new data that I'm discovering that we can really help those people because
it's always been a super, super sticky spot, because if we give those people a bunch of
iron, then the cancer just gobbles it up and you're basically feeding that person's cancer
when you're trying to treat the anemia, but you're stuck between a rock and a hard place
because the patient has anemia, and then how do you treat the anemia?
They have low red blood cell count and you're trying to build it up in a low hemoglobin and
you give them iron, but it could actually end up feeding the cancer.
So we're really stuck, but there's some new data that's really cool, that's really exciting
that we're starting on some patients before I get the video out, but we'll have that out
very soon.
A whole bunch of new information that I'm going to be putting together for my cancer genes
Siri as well.
So watch for some new videos on the cancer genes that I'm discovering with new genes
that can relate to different pieces that add to the cause of a person's cancer and can
really help a person deal with cancer.
So even though we might have done your genetic review already, there are new things that
I'm finding out all the time.
So we may want to talk again about your genes when you watch some of these videos.
Other questions that people have said did that I want to go over before I open it up for
questions?
Question that we commonly get is timing of supplements.
There are certain supplements that I recommend that does require specific timing, needing
that you want to take them at a specific time of day or at a specific time of the day around
what you're doing as far as food intake.
We need that.
Some supplements.
It's okay to take with food.
Some supplements you want to take on an empty stomach.
Some supplements you want to take a couple of hours after, other supplements, some supplements
you want to take right in the morning, some you want to take at night before you go to bed.
Some you want to take on an empty stomach.
So that does get very confusing.
But if I've recommended a supplement to you and I haven't given you any data about you
how I want to take this on an empty stomach or this is a homeopath.
So you're taking this away from any time you have mint in your mouth or this is an enzyme
that we're using to help digest your cancer.
So we want to take this away from food from about an hour away from food or this is a supplement
we're trying to get your liver to flush in a phase 2.5 phase 3 purpose.
So we want to take this after the bitter supplement.
If I didn't give you that data that it doesn't matter when you take the supplement.
So just so you know, if I didn't give you specific data on when you should take a supplement
that it really doesn't matter whether you take the supplement with food or not.
Most of the supplements that we use are food-based supplements.
So does it matter if you take it with food or not?
Not really, not really.
So is it sometimes better to take them outside of food so you don't quote unquote water down
the supplement maybe, but everybody's different.
Sometimes people take supplements on an empty stomach that are good food-based supplements.
So it shouldn't make any difference if they take them on an empty stomach but they get
a tummy ache from them.
So you're going to have to try that yourself, not everybody is the same.
So if I didn't give you specific data when to take it, you could take it any time of the
day.
Facebook rules, we're getting a lot more people, a lot more patients on our Facebook page
which is wonderful.
We do have some rules, now I'm not stating these rules because anybody's broken any rules
because they haven't.
Matter of fact, I think she posted something, she said I'm not sure if this is right
to post this.
It's about another individual that has cancer that she knows and that's fine to post things
like that that you want somebody, you know, they were a family and if we want to be prayed
for someone, that's really great.
Do remember, though, this Facebook page is primarily for our patients.
So though I appreciate it, if you post something like that or I appreciate it if you post, maybe
a question about your loved one or about your child, understand that's not really what
this is for.
So the Facebook page is for those who paid for a full plan so that's really what the purpose
of it's for.
So try to keep to your personal questions and your personal things that would inspire
others on the board and think of it in that way.
We don't want it just to become a random Facebook page either.
So I'm not saying anything, man, I want anything that was posted up to this point in time.
We just want to keep in mind that piece that it's for all of our patients.
Facebook questions.
This is again, the Facebook page is for you to ask questions.
So and I purposely created it for there to be interaction.
I want you to be answering each other's questions and we see that all the time.
What a blessed it is.
So everybody's answering other people's questions.
And I do notice that like on the essential oils questions, some people are very educated.
They've been doing essential oils for a long time.
Mike is one of those people that he's posting things on the essential oil page, some different
different ideas on what a person could do.
And then he always puts it there very professionally.
Please check with Dr. Cutters about this for you.
And I thank you for that.
That should just be a without saying.
We're not advocating or can the clinic advocate anything anybody else is doing
even a recipe that they're using.
It might not be valid for you.
Make sure that you're checking your binder that a recipe that somebody else posts is not necessarily something you could eat.
Everybody's on a different diet, an essential oil that might be great for one person might not be great for another person.
So I don't want you as patients to not give your great insight to other people.
But I also don't want you to have to type in a little caveat that please ask Dr. Cutters first.
That should just be that should just be a given.
So I want you to give your knowledge to other people.
But I also want that other person who's read it to know enough, to have enough common sense to know that boy,
if maybe this isn't what I should do, and to ask me, and my opinion,
and to make sure you look at the rules that we gave you with your diet to see if it fits as well.
And then our DNA kit is in.
So we know that a lot of people did the 23 of me and remember our software changed.
So we could read the 23 of me data.
So if you already did the 23 of me, you do not need to do our new DNA kit.
But our new, if you have not done the 23 of me yet, then we want you to do our DNA kit.
So contact our office.
If you have not done the 23 of me, then you're ready to do a DNA kit.
And we want to get that done.
Now, that DNA kit is to measure steps, single nucleotide polymorphisms.
Those are genetic defects or genetic variants that we want to look at that have to do with cancer genes.
That's what we're talking about in my book here, different things in your genes that can can be a piece of the cause of your cancer and can be the piece of the cure for your cancer.
So we want to get everybody's genetics run.
So if you haven't had your genetics either, 23 of me or our kit, make sure you contact our office so we can get a kit out to you.
So I know Jed has called multiple people, everybody on the list and quite honestly did not hear back from the vast majority of those people she left messages with.
So if you're on this call and you have not had your DNA run, it's time to do that, get a hold of the office so we could get a kit out to you.
And then lastly, we had a number of IVG tests coming back in people doing it for their second, third, and even fourth time.
And we're starting to see these trends.
Now, that's where the beauty of the IVG comes in.
It's one thing to get an IVG score.
And great, I have a score of 32.
Well, I don't know what my score was before.
So how am I trending up or am I trending down?
How is this going?
I just don't know.
But when you start to get your second and your third test back, and if we're trending up, then we need to do some tweaking of what we're doing.
If we're trending down, then we are on the right track and we're doing the right things.
Even though you might still be struggling with a lot of things, we know that the cancer is starting to arrest.
So remember what the IVG is measuring.
The IVG is completely different than the D&A kit, even though this is a D&A test.
So the D&A kit or the 23 and me or our D&A kit is measuring genetic defects or variants of different genes.
The IVG test is measuring free cell D&A, means circulating cells.
It's measuring circulating tumor cells.
And on those circulating tumor cells, it's measuring, is the, are the oncogenes?
Those are the genes that stimulate cancer growth.
Are they turned on?
And are the tumor suppressor genes?
Those are the genes that suppress that tumor that turn off a cancer, that slow a cancer.
Are they turned on or off?
So the higher the IVG score, that means the more of your oncogenes are turned on
and the fewer suppressor genes are turned on.
And the lower the score, the more oncogenes are turned off
and the tumor suppressor genes are turned on.
So we want the tumor suppressor genes to be up-regulated to be turned on.
We want the tumor oncogenes to be down-regulated or turned off.
That has to do with whether they're methylated or not.
So not to get too technical, we want a lower score.
So we want our score to tread down.
So if it's tread being up, we need to tweak some things.
Now, plus or minus five, six, eight points, not too worried about that.
It can bounce around a little bit depending upon your stress levels,
depending upon your diet, depending upon what you're doing as far as nutrition goes.
Other things that are going on in your life,
stimulation of your immune system, suppression of your immune system.
These are all things that could cause cancer to grow
or could cause cancer to slow.
So as we look at this over multiple tests,
we want to look at the trend.
So we had other questions just come in.
Random questions.
Is there anything unhealthy about popcorn
if made un-a-stove with coconut oil?
Great question.
Is popcorn good for you or bad for you?
Well, number one, is it organic popcorn or is it regular popcorn?
If it's regular popcorn, it's going to be genetically modified corn.
So there is zero good things for you,
genetically modified corn.
So period, it's organic popcorn with coconut oil.
Well, that's good then, right?
Well, corn doesn't grain.
Remember, it's not a vegetable.
Corn doesn't grain.
It's not a vegetable.
So it's simply carbohydrates.
Is there any value in eating corn?
No.
Matter of fact, corn can also be a highly sensitive thing.
Meaning there's probably the most food sensitive thing
that, I mean, most common food sensitivity is gluten,
dairy, soy, and corn.
Maybe I could think of a few other things.
So is there any value in corn?
Is there anything, but the question is,
is there anything unhealthy about eating?
Let's put it organic popcorn,
if made on a stove, come with coconut oil.
No, if that can be your stack,
and that's going to be your little stack for the day,
then go for it.
I don't want to knock it,
because that can be or searching for something to eat here.
But don't call it something that's good for you.
So this is going to be your cheat stack.
You're going to have a little popcorn with some sea salt,
and it's organic, and you made it with coconut oil,
so you're getting a good fat with it.
So there's nothing really wrong with it.
Just make sure you don't have any sensitivity issues to corn.
How would I know that?
Well, you can run a test.
There's some different blood tests that we can do,
if you really want to know,
if you have any corn sensitivities,
if you have any antibodies to corn,
and corn, different proteins in corn.
But you could also notice,
do I get a tummy ache after I eat it?
Does it bother me?
Do I get a headache?
Do I get stuffy after it?
So you could notice if I have any symptoms
after eating corn as well.
But otherwise, don't go ahead and ham that.
Understand it's a carbohydrate.
It's not a protein.
It's not a vegetable.
All right, we are going to open this up
and unmute everybody and open it up for questions.
Any questions?
Dr. Connors?
Hi.
It's Lisa.
Hi, Lisa.
Nicole, I have a question.
Just about the different forms of B12.
The one I have for you is the hydroxylobololine.
And what's the difference in like there's one
a liquid one out there that's called vegan safe
and it's a methyl and a ADN,
another cobalmolamine.
Okay, so I'm going to mute everybody.
So if everybody's going to be muted while I answer this, okay.
All right, so there's several different forms of B12.
There's hydroxylobolamine.
There's adenosylobolamine.
And then there's methylobolamine.
So those are the three
quote-unquote natural forms of B12.
There's other forms of B12 that are natural.
Sayeto-commolamine is one of them.
There's a few other ones.
But the three that are found in the human body
are hydroxy-commolamine,
adenosyl-commolamine,
and methyl-commolamine.
What's the difference in them?
The difference is how hard they push different
pathways.
So I don't know if I can find because I am not at the computer
that I normally have by my
hygienic pictures on there.
So I can't pull it up right now.
But they're the main pathways that we're looking at
is the methionine pathway,
the folate pathway,
and the biopteran pathway.
Not to get too technical,
but take it in
too many methyl groups
can be harmful.
So we want to be careful.
Remember, I said if you watched any of my genetic videos
and we've got over your genetics
that you have two main purposes in life.
What is to make ATP?
And what is to make methyl groups?
Well, that part of making methyl group
is all about balance.
So one of the major mistakes
with doctors that are looking at genetics
and they're kind of novices looking at genetics,
they'll look at especially the folate pathway
and look at the MTHFR gene
and go, oh my goodness,
you have a defect in your MTHFR gene.
We're going to give you methyl folate
and methyl-commolamine because that will help
that pathway.
Will it help that pathway?
Yes, it will.
It will push that pathway very strongly.
And that's, is that good for our cancer patient
or any patient
as looking at the big picture?
It can be very harmful,
especially for our cancer patient.
So we talk about tumor suppressor genes
and tumor oncogenes
and the IV gene test.
What is the IV gene test measuring?
It's measuring whether these tumor suppressor genes
are turned on or turned off.
What does that mean?
It means whether they're methylated or not.
Oh, well, what is methylation due to a gene?
Methylation turns the gene off.
Oh, is that good or bad?
It depends on what gene we're talking about.
Well, don't we want our tumor oncogenes
to be turned off?
Yes, we do.
But if you're just going to take a whole
much of methyl products,
you are also contributing to over-methylation
and turning off tumor suppressor genes.
So it's not as simple as,
oh, we have a deficiency here.
So we're going to take this product
or we have a defect here.
So we're going to take this product.
You can't treat the gene that way.
And you can't treat an adenemia that way.
If I have a B12 adenemia,
most frequently has nothing to do
with whether I have an FB12.
It's whether the B12 could get into the cell.
So you don't want to give a methyl B12.
You want to give a hydroxy B12
or an adenosyl B12.
Because you don't want to push that methyl pathway.
And then it even gets more technical.
If we give a lot of methyl products
and give methyl folate products
or methyl cobalamine products,
we will push what's called the biopterant pathway.
And the biopterant pathway
is the pathway that makes neurotransmitters.
Neurotransmitters.
That's what's going on in my brain, right?
Yes, it is.
So the brain neurotransmitters,
epinephrine, nor epinephrine,
dopamine, and serotonin
all are be made
through that biopterant pathway.
If I'm going to push that pathway,
I'm going to upregulate
the production of those neurotransmitters,
which can be a bad thing.
So an upregulation of my dopamine,
because I'm taking a bunch of methyl cobalometer,
methyl folate,
is going to make me a lot more agitated,
a lot more ADD, ADHD person.
If upregulation of my serotonin
is not going to make me more happy,
it's going to make me more angry.
So remember,
everything in my body is about balance.
There's not really a bad guy
and a good guy.
It's about that balance.
And when we artificially
disturb that balance with
not understanding biochemistry,
like giving too many methyl groups,
we can really throw things off.
So we don't want to give a lot of methyl groups
to cancer patients.
We don't want to give a lot of methyl groups
to anybody with mood issues
or hormonal balance issues,
any type of anxiety issues,
any type of ADD issues,
any type of OCD type issues.
You've got to really be careful with those people.
So no cancer patients really get methyl groups.
Sometimes I've allowed you
if you came to me and you're taking a methyl B12,
but it's a really low dose,
like 500 micrograms.
I say, fine, you could take that.
But if you're taking more
than 1,000 micrograms of methyl B12,
then you're really starting to push that pathway.
So it is very important.
The type of B12,
the type of folate that you're using,
that's why it's always better
to get things through your food.
If you noticed,
when I've done your genetics,
looked at your folate pathway,
if even if you had a MTHFR defect,
I'd say I'd rather have you
push that pathway naturally
through eating a lot more leafy green vegetables
that give you a folate product or a medical product.
Okay, I'm going to invite you.
And if you asked a question
in the last two minutes, I didn't hear it so.
Thank you.
Dr. Connors, I just,
this is Deb's words.
I just got back my,
oh, arterial scanning, whatever,
to see if you have blood spots and whatever.
But anyway,
they said I had the beginning of osteoporosis.
I'm confused about
various vitamin Ks that help you absorb
vitamin D into your bones.
Let's slow that down.
Okay.
Testos.
Sure, I'm going to mute everybody
and I'll discuss that too.
Okay, so there are multiple different types of vitamin K.
So the first vitamin K
that they tend to talk about is
the vitamin K1, which is the vitamin K that helps in clotting.
And they tell you if you're on
because you had a stroke risk or a blood pressure issue
and they have you on a blood thinner,
don't take any vitamin K products.
And don't take,
don't eat a lot of green leafy vegetables
that have vitamin K in them
because that's going to, you know,
make know the fact that you're taking this anti-clotting medication.
And is there truth to that?
Yes, there is truth to that.
Except one thing,
really what they're talking about
though they never delineate this,
it's the vitamin K1 factor
that really is the anti,
is the clotting factor vitamin.
So if you have clotting issues
where you're forming a lot of clots,
then you shouldn't take vitamin K1.
If you have bleeding issues where you have constant nose bleeds
and you can't stop that nose bleed
or when you do bleed,
you don't clot very well
and you're bruising constantly
and you're not clotting.
Now if you're not on an anti-coagulant medication,
then you probably are deficient in K1.
Now it's pretty hard to be deficient in K1
though I've had numerous patients that were
because they were like allergic to vegetables in their mind.
They weren't really allergic to vegetables
but they didn't like to eat vegetables.
Yes, I've had patients that never ever ever ate vegetables.
Those are the people that will be deficient in K1
and they will have frequent nose bleeds and frequent issues.
Now there's a whole bunch of things that can cause that
other than K1 deficiencies.
But I've had a few patients over the years
that actually had a K1 deficiency.
But K1 is not the vitamin K that gets vitamin D into the bones
and prevents osteoporosis.
It's vitamin K2.
So vitamin K2 is what helps prevent osteoporosis.
Matter of fact, we have heard over the years
that you should, if you're an osteoporosis,
you should be taking vitamin D and you should be taking calcium.
Well, the truth is is that if you're deficient in vitamin K2
which is very difficult to get through our food,
if you're deficient in K2, then you could take a whole bunch of D
and a whole bunch of calcium
and you'll probably just get hard need of the arteries.
Matter of fact, there's been multiple studies show
that women, the studies were on women, I'm sorry,
that were on 1,500 milligrams, the prescribed dose of calcium,
for multiple years, they have a multi-fold increase
in risk of catheter sclerosis.
So they have increased hearted arteries,
increased heart attack,
cordinary artery disease risk, big time.
So then they thought, oh, I'm going to say,
it's better pull that idea off,
don't recommend calcium, it's myths.
No longer, calcium is no longer recommended.
So if your doctor's recommended it,
it increased high dose calcium to prevent osteoporosis,
he's not reading the literature because he's not supposed
to be recommending that anymore.
The recommendation is supposed to be,
increase K2.
Now, the problem is it's very difficult to find a good source of K2
unless you're Japanese and you're eating natto.
So we're not talking about natto enzyme or nato kinase.
We're talking about natto, the food, which is a fermented soy.
Now, if you've not ever eaten natto,
I wouldn't suggest you run out to your natural Japanese restaurant
and get some because it is an acquired taste.
It is the most nasty horrible thing I've ever tasted
in my life, to be honest with you.
I think if you ate it since you were two years old,
you'd probably acquire a taste.
Matter of fact, areas in Japan, it's only certain areas in Japan
that still eat natto.
They're incident of heart disease,
their incidence of cancer is reduced,
their incidence of osteoporosis is almost zero.
Matter of fact, I was going to do a video on vitamin K2
here on this week too, so I'll get more of this information out,
so it's kind of funny that you ask me about this right now.
But vitamin K2 is a product we changed our vitamin D to add K2 to it.
So our old private label, brand of vitamin D liquid droppers,
has K2 at it now.
And my next week, we're going to actually have a product of straight K2
with all the all-food-based vitamin A and vitamin D and co-Q10 in it,
that I'm going to start taking.
I bought it for me first because it is so interesting this data
and I'm going to put on a video on the fat-soluble vitamins
and the reason why we need them because our food is almost completely depleted
on them, so it's very difficult to get it in.
But it is vitamin K2,
Deb that you need, it's in the cutter's clinic-brained vitamin D liquid dropper.
That's the only way I have it right now.
I would be careful with some other brands,
and I don't need to be nitpicky, but I'm going to be super nitpicky here.
The type of vitamin K2 that you have to have, now this gets a little technical,
but you go back to your biochemistry class,
an organic chemistry class, certain things had a cis and a transformed cis CIS,
or trans-T-R-A-N-S.
That's the configuration of the protein of the molecule.
And you have to have vitamin K2 in a specific form
and when there was done some independent labs on some vitamin K2,
now the way you'll see it labeled is vitamin K2 MK4 or MK7.
You MK4 and MK7 are both good forms of vitamin K2.
Either one of those are great forms of vitamin K2.
The problem is it has to be in a specific form.
And if it's in the wrong form, then which is a lot cheaper to make,
it's basically worthless to the human body.
So you really have to have a product that has it independently tested.
There was one product on the market that boasted so much,
I can't remember the dosage of vitamin K2 that was in it.
It was independently tested and then all of a sudden they sold it at a high discount
and to sell them out because it wasn't what was really on the label.
So be careful of that too.
So I will be posting a video about the other product that we have,
but the one product that we have that private label is independently tested.
Okay, I'm unmuted, everybody.
Hopefully that answers your question, Deb.
Yeah, can I ask?
One, the additional.
They recommended they get your kidneys function tested.
I don't, do we truly need that?
It depends on the person.
Is it good to get a kidney function test if you have some problems?
Then yes, it is.
Is it imperative that every single person gets every lab test out there at a kidney function test?
No.
If your urine output is good, and you don't have any flake paid,
and you don't think that you have stones,
I don't necessarily think it's going to get a kidney function test.
Okay.
Dr. Connors, it's Patty and Nebraska.
Hello, Patty.
Hello there.
I'm doing very well and very pleased with that.
And it's coming on the three months to get my thermal scan done again.
I have found a provider in Lincoln or Omaha, Nebraska.
It just depends where I could get the appointment.
How do I have a position here order?
Do I have them call you for the order?
I wasn't sure how that might work.
You could have them call us.
Most of the thermography labs don't need a physician's order,
but if they need one, they can call us and we'll give that to them.
Just make sure it's a Betty thermo clinic.
Say it again.
Make sure they're using the Betty thermo equipment.
Okay, it was the same company.
I googled it through what is in my scan.
Okay, perfect.
That's good.
From the clinic.
So it's, I can't believe it's going to be three months
and I feel better than most healthy people.
Well, that's good because you are a healthy person.
That's what I think.
That's right.
That's the battle.
But yeah, so it's going well, I'm just pretty pleased.
Oh, good.
That's good.
I'd like to hear those things.
Yeah.
Dr. Canterford, some of us who have like hair thinning from treatments,
would you discourage any of the products that are claimed to help with like
regenerate eyebrow or eyelash growth?
It depends on what it is.
If it's like a keratin product, no, you can use that.
There's some good products that could really
give thicker hair.
And it's just using the minerals that are found in hair
and the different trends that are found in hair.
But you know, we have a product that I think is called H.S.
Head, Hair, Skin and Dales.
And I have to look at it because we haven't really used it for any cancer patients.
So I have to look and see what the ingredients are.
But there's other products out there.
If you have a question about a product,
just post the, take a picture of the back of the ingredients
and you can post it on the Facebook page.
If you don't make a comment, yeah, or they don't.
Okay.
Most of these are like, um,
I'm just going to put it on top of the eye brow area.
Oh, well, I'm not familiar with those.
So let me know what they are.
Okay.
Dr. Poners?
Uh-huh.
This is Terry Joe.
Am I have a question about the K2K1?
I've been taking K2 to go with long with my quad liver oil,
the foam is a projectile.
Yep.
And it looks, but I'm also having bleeding from my tumor.
Sometimes quite scary.
I'm thinking, well, you might need to,
would I need to add some K1?
Yeah.
Just keep taking the K2, but add the K1.
So the K2 does not did your blood,
but it's not really going to help the clotting so much.
Okay.
I'm going to go out and get some K1.
Now I've been taking life extension.
Okay.
That I hate to say it, and we'll have to,
this won't go out to the general public,
but life extension was the company that got nailed.
And the K2 that was in there was all wrong, K2.
Okay.
But usually I like their products.
You know, most of their products I really like,
but you know, this is where it gets back to.
What's on the label?
Is it always what's in the product?
Did you have to,
you know, that's why I'm toured almost every place
of the companies that we sell products?
Because if they're not doing
their own lab work and stuff that comes in,
that's why sometimes we're back ordered on stuff
because the, you know, the company that I get it from,
they got to ship it in and they tested it
and they rejected the whole shipment.
So it goes all back to the source
and then they're back ordered on it.
So is there one that I can go out and buy?
We're going to have this other higher level K2.
I ordered it last week.
They were out of it to tell they were hoping to get it in this week
and that I, they're going to ship it out.
So we probably, they probably won't ship out from them
to us and tell like tomorrow or Friday.
So we probably won't get it until next week.
The K2 that we have in our vitamin D is, is a lower.
So we're talking about the K2.K1 here.
So the K1 I think is safe to find most brands out there.
It's the K2 that's the important one.
Okay.
We can get the right one.
Because I need the K2 because I'm also
bordering on osteoporosis.
Yeah.
Well, we're going to find what I do this video
that it's, it's a lot more than osteoporosis
that could really help with cancer as well.
Awesome.
Can you give us a dose on the vitamin K2?
Well, it really depends.
So we're going to actually have a K2 test.
But the, the hyperdose on K2 is important to begin with
and then you drop the dose down.
So like our dose, if that's in the vitamin D,
is only what I think is the micrograms,
which is not even close to a hyperdose.
So hyperdose is like 2,000 micrograms.
So how can you get that?
You can't even get it through the vitamin D.
That's why I, that's why I went to this other product
to be able to hyperdose.
Thank you.
Dr. Connors.
It's Lisa again.
What's so ironic is I literally today at my dentist
just bought a vitamin D spray from her.
And it's by Physica and it's a D.
And the K2 is menacquinone 7.
So menacquinone is shortened as MK.
So you're either going to MK4 or MK7.
And that's just fine.
So that's good.
Okay.
And it's 120 micrograms.
We just don't know if it's a cis or a trans.
So we're just going to trust that they put the rights
stuff in there.
Okay.
Well, next time I'm going to get yours.
But I can't believe this question came up and I just bought it.
Yeah.
Okay. Good.
Thank you.
All right.
So we will get this posted on Facebook probably tonight
and make sure you use Facebook correctly.
Get your questions up there.
And if you have questions about a supplement just like
Melissa, just take a picture of the back of it.
So I can see the ingredients.
And post a picture up there.
Or that will help a lot of people.
So.
All right.
Thanks, you guys.
Thank you, Dr.
Well, thank you all.
Bye bye, though.
Bye, Dr.